you dare enter his house
he W K&Z coming direct to you
from Studio City and areas beyond
you
it's a beautiful day to be alive the
birds are singing the squirrels are
[ __ ] most importantly you hear you're
swinging dick and giving our bubblegum
they give you another day the [ __ ] we'll
go out and tell these [ __ ]
which really crack-a-lackin' you
understand me smart they [ __ ] it's a
whole new set of [ __ ] rules there's a
whole new bag of wreaths awaiting field
I got jujitsu today I'm gonna meet some
[ __ ] people again and here beat will
be lied to my white people I gotta meet
somebody tonight too right yeah you know
how we [ __ ] do it
it never ends [ __ ] people always
say when is my ship gonna come in your
ship is here you're doing something
you're living your legs are [ __ ]
moving
you're smoking dope you're interacting
with these [ __ ] morons what else do
you want but this I did a thousand
things already this more is ten o'clock
I'm [ __ ] exhausted
I've been going since [ __ ] 6:35 this
moment you understand I just keep up the
daughter part whole [ __ ] thing I'm
here now we're gonna smoke a little
reefer I'm gonna put my rash guard on
put my [ __ ] did you two get the [ __ ]
out of here do a little warm-up to
hyperventilate the low but see if this
[ __ ] operation work they did work I'm
breathing tremendous these days
[Applause]
which is finishing off this [ __ ]
Skywalker and I'm kicking in this move
Yoda look a perfect containment ring you
know you're gonna have a [ __ ] problem
when somebody gives you something purple
is the [ __ ] that kill [ __ ] them prints
and money the [ __ ] lizard whatever
his [ __ ] name is y'all see Bonnie
don't wanna put the [ __ ] is dead
that's the wheelie smoke as far as this
[ __ ] scrap walking I can feel the
tingles and my scalp it's like putting
dandruff shampoo on understand this how
good this [ __ ] reference you think and
a happy idea telephone a smoking reefer
outside if I wasn't smoking the best
that you [ __ ] yeah that's uncle Joey
doesn't matter wish your [ __ ] time the
smoke suits us were here now I love the
taste of this in a hookah here take my
[ __ ] hookah between my legs
suck on that [ __ ] hammer Boober you
[ __ ] humus dick uncle Joey's here
[ __ ] it's time to get the party started
if you're depressed snap out of it you
got parents you got legs you got [ __ ]
arms you got a [ __ ] way to much
somebody get out there there's no reason
to be I'm depressed what are you [ __ ]
depressed about I've never been
depressed in my life and I thought not
some depression go 80 [ __ ] times you
understand me when the depression toward
not saying you thumps up my dick I'm not
depressed but we talked about it it's
time to burn some [ __ ] trees
the pressed feeling goomy
the [ __ ] ball with people as upper
body up that Isis is watching this [ __ ]
the best hahaha don't get [ __ ] the
press we ain't got time to bleed [ __ ]
with a Church of what's happening now
it's not a podcast it's a state of mind
you [ __ ] Joel Olsteen - suck my dick
with Anthony at Ronnies or whatever his
name is with his [ __ ] barbecue coals
we're a state of mind we don't walk on
coals we welcome [ __ ] concrete
understand me [ __ ] these [ __ ] what
the Sun will shine the sun will come out
tomorrow' got a [ __ ] experiment
understand me this is it the only you
don't need no [ __ ] at all you don't
need no Babel law you don't need no
[ __ ] pills this is it God put these
[ __ ] things on everything for we
think they're the Martians we smoke them
we for 30 [ __ ] years we know you're
waiting for them
get your [ __ ] together let's smoke
somebody's [ __ ] death right here
boop boop be doop boop boop be doop as
it's Monday here I'm sorry if you're not
gonna go all out put back the bed stop
wasting people's time you're rested you
[ __ ] claim you're doubted your boss
is gonna be out when it's humid you
don't want your nuts [ __ ] crazy going
to your leg and I say this is how we do
it here
we want our goals we said our prayers
you got your [ __ ] gun clean and oil
just in case you got a Papa capita
[ __ ] on a Monday it's a bad day
to public hapless sometimes you got a
public capital
this is the way that made [ __ ] senator
Cruz tap out that [ __ ] said
listen ain't no reason to run for
president
miss Montana [ __ ] [ __ ] Hilary [ __ ] Trump
let that be with this [ __ ] bad
[ __ ] out they would be be
weapons understanding
I'm gonna I said nock the police
breathing technique smoking reefer from
the diaphragm you understand me if I
[ __ ] around
tell yourself [ __ ] stories and [ __ ]
it's Monday [ __ ] I don't want to hear
it
some people ate lunch some people are
getting up and getting told to [ __ ] it
up
tuned up today are you supposed to be
literally the sun's I don't get some
vitamin D I'm breathing the most
important thing the podcast is up go to
[ __ ] in the Church of what's happening
now it's ready we talk about george
megrath the camel brett well you should
take this [ __ ] chance dragging in the
16 we talk about a lot of [ __ ] charities
how they're robbing [ __ ] you
know just [ __ ] that weed whatever wait
there should we smoke a little ball Joey
what type of [ __ ] question is that
but kinda should we smoke another bowl
do you think you'd be want somebody who
reads Yelp and [ __ ] makes notes in
this [ __ ] [ __ ] people
I'm powerful broke this I got a big date
tonight kiss baby sometimes you got a
big day worry about it come outside slip
to what he's [ __ ] through and the
[ __ ] big day goes away that's it you
just go out and say I'm slinging thick
and give it out a lottery tickets
a lot of it biggest one of the joy I
have no [ __ ] idea rent just smoke
your [ __ ] reefer finish up I might
wrap this [ __ ] thing up I love you
guys that's why do this to get your
[ __ ] motivate to get you out there
don't take nothing from nobody don't
take [ __ ] from nobody today it is the
bucket it's your world [ __ ]
these Martians are visiting understand
it's your [ __ ] world you want should
i do a snapchat and have friends get the
[ __ ] out of here go mingle oh man let
him know where you're from
let him know it got you there you know
I'm saying [ __ ] people he wants to be
on snapchat let's snap the [ __ ] is wrong
with you people are getting stabbed and
Indonesian and you want to snapchat
so that's it and that's that pulled up
the way I'm supposed to be on a Monday
I'm ready to go out there amongst these
[ __ ] wolfson or whatever that's it I
don't know what else to tell you my
[ __ ] little paperclip to clean out my
boat better uncle Joey hold school now
listen it's all old school it's a lot
better he cut through a lot of [ __ ]
all these people give you a drum we're
gonna compute it and now somebody knows
I'm taking over from what
mind your business
as the word and a mighty business who
gives a [ __ ]
another do with you but he's a nice guy
food is a fun
and that's it mess then I got breathing
reefer I'm picking up an abuse I'm going
to a weed store before jujitsu on
picking up my it's a nice day you leave
your weakness [ __ ] car the Sun
[ __ ] dries it I got plans [ __ ]
have a great day you know you uncle Joey
loves you boy
I thought I'm waiting to get on said
Jessica's on their beam yeah oh yeah
Luna our heartache cool go ahead a lot
more okay I walk I'll enjoy it
atomic force I win a half with her it's
good out here's a good day to be alive
understand me smile grab your balls and
the rest is up to you uncle Joey here
we're gonna take two steps to the ring
gonna have em all along the storm side I
love you [ __ ] stay black to
have a great day they'll take [ __ ] from
nobody